um yeah so this came up a lot quicker
than I thought it would so folks much to
my still frankly stunned self sense of I
don't know just I'm I I don't even
really have words I am on the cusp of
20,000 subscribers and this has happened
quick like I have gotten almost 3,000
subscribers in just the last week which
is insane like awesome but insane and I
have a guy I had been percolating a
number of different ideas ways to
celebrate 20,000 subscribers I didn't
think it was gonna have to pull the
trigger on any of these until like close
to the end of the year but here we are
so um after sort of thinking about what
I the ideas that I had the work involved
in pulling them together as well as sort
of pulling my patrons over on the
patreon plug what I'm gonna be doing is
I'm gonna be doing another Q&A a Q&A is
how I marked the 10,000 subscriber mark
back in January so I'm going to do
another one so this is me inviting you
to ask your questions and get them
answered now please I'm gonna put a link
to the last Q&A that I did down in the
description please watch that first
stand do not ask me questions that were
already asked there because like last
time I'm going to make an effort to try
and answer in some or at least touch on
in some way every question that I get
but I'm not gonna answer questions that
I already answered last video so check
out that video first then after having
done that go ahead and ask your
questions and if for whatever reason
it's not a question you want to leave in
a comment you can send it to Council of
geeks at gmail.com
that's my email so send them in once I
clear 20,000 which is yeah coming up
quickly so let's let's say I don't know
in the next two weeks or so I will
probably shoot the response the QA
response to the to these now for future
like 30,000 so I'm not gonna do with QA
every 10,000 well I'm not gonna say I'm
not I'm not gonna plan to do a Q&A every
10,000 subscribers especially not if I
keep anywhere near this growth pace cuz
then it's just gonna get old really
really really quick I might find try and
find a different way to mark the next
10,000 if and when I get there but yeah
so that's it QA questions are open drop
them down on the comments get him in
soon um because like I said I'm crossing
this threshold a lot faster than I
thought I would be so yeah there you go
drop them down below
ask them I'll answer them see you when I
get to that thanks guys this is uh this
is nuts
like awesome nuts the best kind of nuts
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you